>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington D.C.
>> And we are thrilled that you
could join us for our first Library
of Congress online conference for educators.
We have a great lineup for the entire
program, but we are super proud to show off
with our keynote speaker, Carol Highsmith.
I'm going to turn the program over to the
Director of Education Outreach, Lee Ann Potter,
and she's going to introduce
our very special guest to you.
>> Thanks Kathy.
I really am delighted to be here as well
and tickled that all of you are joining us.
Thrilled to be introducing two
of our guests this evening.
The first is Carol Highsmith.
Carol is a distinguished and richly
published American photographer.
She has donated her work to the
Library of Congress since 1992.
Starting in 2002, Highsmith provided scans
or photographs that she shot digitally
with new donations to allow rapid
online access throughout the world.
If you have poked around the library's
website at any length and stumbled
across some really extraordinary
photography in recent years,
you are certainly familiar with Carol's work.
Joining Carol is Helena Zinkham.
Helena is the chief of the Prints and
Photographs Division at the Library of Congress.
Helene joined the Library Prints
and Photographs Division in 1984.
She fell in love with pictures while working
at the Maryland Historical Society in 1977,
and to this day, enjoys helping
people discover the rich resources
in public collections of the library.
We are thrilled to have both of you with us
tonight and tickled that all of you are here
and looking forward to an outstanding session.
Thank you.
>> Thank you Lee Ann.
Great pleasure on my part to be getting ready
to meet everyone and host this conversation.
The keynote session for the online
conference Library of Congress and teachers,
unlike in the [inaudible] primary resources, it
offers all of us the opportunity to learn from
and talk with a prolific creator
of primary visual sources.
And so the theme for this afternoon will be
preserving our communities with photography.
I probably should have mentioned
that my voice is Helena Zinkham.
We'll meet Carol in just a moment.
I will ask the obvious questions on your behalf,
starting with how Carol became interested
in photography, her historical mentor, how
she fell in love with the Library of Congress
by photographing our magnificent Jefferson
Building in Washington D.C. And then,
how her daily life work documenting historic
buildings evolved into a magnificent vision.
And she launched her journey to act on her dream
and create a visual profile of all 50 states
and territories throughout our country.
And that's where we'll spend most of our time.
How Carol captures the essence of
communities, how an extraordinary body
of primary sources is being created
that you can use and reuse right now.
It's copyright-free and all
online at the Library of Congress.
We're going to take a look at several states,
then travel with Carol through Alabama,
followed by vanishing America,
communities as people,
and the beauties in the natural environment.
There's time at the end for
your questions, of course.
You can quiz Carol about the tools of her
trade or ask anything else you're interested
in about using her archive or perhaps
even photographing your own communities
with students.
And I'm going to switch to our first slide now.
And naturally enough, get
ready to say all aboard.
Are you ready to ride?
I'll turn it over to Carol,
who can give us a quick hello.
>> Hi Helena.
Thank you so much.
I'm honored and so excited to be
included in this landmark webinar.
You know, until I took up photography in
my 30s, I had barely picked up a camera.
It was just that my dad was
always taking photographs of us,
so I think subconsciously
I was aware of photography.
I wasn't really a serious student, but
when I started in the world of work,
all of a sudden I became very serious.
And I put myself through school
working in the broadcasting industry.
And one day I won a trip
to Russia and also China.
Well, it's kind of hard to go to
those places, especially when I went,
and not take really kind of amazing photographs.
And so when I got back I thought,
you know, I like photography.
This is interesting.
So I took some photography courses,
and one day on a class assignment,
I took a friend into the Willard Hotel.
Now the Willard Hotel used to be grand.
It was a hotel of presidents.
It was only two blocks from the White House.
But when I went in there,
it was just a rat trap.
It was a mess.
As a matter of fact, there were rats the
size of cats running around in the halls.
Thank goodness the Willard Hotel was
saved, and I was asked if I would
like to photograph the whole restoration.
One day I noticed this man was
walking through with a whole mitt full
of photographs, and I said to him, what's this?
What do you have?
And he said well you know, there were no
architectural drawings for this grand hotel,
so we used photographs to
put it back together again.
And he told me about this
woman, Frances Benjamin Johnston
who had worked in the Willard during 1901.
And he told me that Frances had donated,
had given away her life's collections
of photographs to the Library of Congress.
Well I was, my interest was piqued.
He invited me down to the library with him, and
I actually went down and saw this collection.
And what she had done was produced tens
of thousands of images on her big heavy,
bulky eight by ten camera all over America.
Starting with photographs of four
sitting presidents and their families,
and then photographs of southern mansions
produced with a Carnegie Foundation grant.
And then photographs of African-American
schools and poor,
white mining communities and
American Indian families.
Okay, I was interested.
Realizing, and this is by the
way a photograph that I had taken
in the Willard Hotel back in 1980.
Realizing that this woman had done, what
she had done for me was life-changing.
I told the curators of the Library of Congress
the day I went down to see her collection
that I would like to photograph, that I
would like to follow in her footsteps.
That I would like to document America too and
give my work to the Library of Congress as well.
Well I think they thought I was a little
nutty, but anyway, that was the beginning
of my interest in following
Francis Benjamin Johnston.
>> Carol, this is Helena.
We're going to load up just a few portraits
of your mentor, your historical mentor,
Miss Johnston so that everyone can
enjoy the size of her camera relative
to our cellphone photography today.
But it sure looks like the
Willard Hotel turned out fine.
The restoration.
>> It was gorgeous.
It was gorgeous.
>> About how many photographs would
you take in a building that size?
>> Well, you know.
>> Do you remember?
>> Interesting.
I was also trying to follow her in
every way, so I was also working
with a bulky four by five camera.
Four inch by five inch film,
which was very slow.
And also, when you take interiors like
this, you have to light them correctly.
So this might have taken five
hours just to light this.
So it wasn't, I maybe took during the,
I think I was in there four years,
maybe 500 to 1000 to 1500
images in the Willard Hotel.
But it wasn't like the type of images
I take today on digital photography.
>> Alright Carol.
While we wait for those next photos to
come up, I mentioned that you, well,
you've been very complementary to the
Library of Congress, and I appreciate that.
What we'll move on to, oh, it
looks like they're coming up now.
>> Anyway, while we're waiting,
let me continue to just chat
about how [inaudible] Francis Benjamin
Johnston's work was and still is.
Well this is a photograph of her.
And you see how huge that camera is.
I mean, how did she carry it around?
I have no idea.
Let me talk about the Library of Congress also.
My dream of traveling America, leaving a mark
behind as Francis Benjamin Johnston had done,
was also made fortunate, possible by a number
of fortunate things that happened to me.
People at the Library of Congress
believed in me and also kind of took me
under their wing, which was amazingly helpful.
They were interested in my Willard
Hotel experience and my photographs,
and as I continued to document Pennsylvania
Avenue, they also were interested
and decided they wanted those images too.
So it was very helpful that the Library
of Congress felt that this was as valuable
to have images in their collection
of current-day events,
as valuable as what Francis Benjamin
Johnston had done during her lifetime
at the turn of the last century.
Look at these magnificent images.
This, for instance, was a slide, a
black and white slide that she colored.
Look at these beautiful children.
She did school children.
She loved school children.
So this was, you know, I look at this
and I just get chill bumps looking
at these images and how beautiful they are.
And remember they're on large
eight by ten film negatives.
Look at this salt mine.
I was just in an exhibition mine
in West Virginia the other day.
And all I could think about was what it was
like for Francis to go in these old mines back
when she went in with her eight by ten camera.
And these beautiful, beautiful historic
scenes of outbuildings of plantations
that Carnegie sent her down
to do all of the south.
And many, many of these buildings are gone now.
I know. I've tried to replicate some.
And look at this.
You can see this one's almost gone.
Thank goodness that Francis
Benjamin Johnston recorded these.
Thank goodness she recorded them.
And see, now, she moved on in age.
But she worked almost all the way to the end.
She lived in New Orleans during her 80s.
And believe it or not, she is buried about ten
minutes from where I live now in Washington D.C.
>> Carol, this is Helena again.
You should also tell them about
Miss Johnston's sense of humor.
In her 80s she called herself the
octo-geranium, a woman of great energy.
>> She was a character and a half.
She really was.
But, you know, we should be indebted to
her for all she did for the United States,
capturing our history the way she did.
It just changed my life.
It really did.
And seeing these images, I decided
that I should follow in her footsteps.
You know, it's interesting, I could never
do what she did because much of it's gone.
But she couldn't do what I've done.
I photograph Washington [inaudible]
places from the air.
I do aerials.
I carry around a camera that's
lighter than what she lugged around.
So now this is the Library of Congress.
I was very fortunate that the
Library of Congress, library staff,
allowed me to go into the iconic
Thomas Jefferson Building.
It was such an experience for me to go in,
and it had never really been
photographed correctly because,
I was able to go up on scaffolding and on
gurneys and get high up and show the art.
Because my cameras were lighter and smaller,
and not the bulky eight by ten camera
that Francis Benjamin Johnston had used.
I was able to take in lighting
that was smaller and lighter.
And so this beautiful building was captured in
a way that it had never been captured before.
And I'm just thrilled, I was
thrilled for the opportunity.
And it was just at the time that
digital photography was starting
to really make its mark.
So at the time I photographed the Library
of Congress I was using a digital camera
that it was actually 39 megapixels.
Now most digital cameras were maybe
5, 10 maybe at the most at that time.
And I was on 39.
So we were able to really
capture with fine quality.
The cameras that I use today
are actually double that amount.
I'm working with the largest
megapixel camera made.
That it, in the commercial realm anyway.
And so the quality is just eye-popping almost.
So it's really an adventure for me to
be able to work with these fine tools.
But because I was able to photograph the
Library of Congress Thomas Jefferson Building,
I learned so much about photography
and digital photography at that time.
>> Carol, I've also enjoyed talking with you
about how you've branched out from the library
to many, many community public libraries.
One of the great symbols throughout our
John Adams building was actually the owl.
I hope is a sign of wisdom.
And [inaudible] we were looking
at her mosaic earlier.
But here we have the Frederick
County Public Library.
And talk just a little bit
about how you find libraries
in different communities in the country.
>> You know, because the Library of
Congress, the staff, and you of course,
are so interested in me capturing small towns,
and every town that I can possibly get to.
There always seems to be a sign to the library.
And I always try to go there because our
libraries are so varied and interesting.
Everything from, of course,
the Library of Congress
and the magnificent Thomas Jefferson
Building, to what they have now,
which are little teeny weeny libraries
that if you walk in a neighborhood,
a lot of times you can see these little,
you know, birdhouse almost libraries.
Where people just go and
put books that they've read,
and then you can take them and
add books that you've read.
So it's so fun.
But also, the other thing about libraries
that I love, and remember I've seen them all
over the United States, is that oftentimes
it's where people go to get on computers.
It's more than just books
now, which is wonderful.
It's a community gathering spot.
And I've seen, you know, buildings, old
store buildings that have become libraries.
I've seen how towns have
adjusted their, you know,
their downtowns to what fits the community.
And of course, everybody loves a library.
Everybody does.
>> Carol, we're going to talk next about what
you've been doing, not just since the days
of Willard and individual buildings
at the Library of Congress.
Oh this is a great picture.
So everyone, that's Carol Highsmith today,
ready for her 50th high school
reunion, believe it or not.
And California was certainly one of
the states Carol traversed many months,
up and down coast, interior and the west.
Carol, I'll go ahead and start
the slides in this section.
And the kinds of things I wondered about is
how do you decide which scenes to photograph?
Because there are millions of choices of course.
And then what kinds of things you've learned
from the experience or even just tell us,
what's it like, life on the road.
>> Well, I love life on the road.
I think I'm a Nomad.
I think it's because all my young life we used
to travel down to see my grandmother and granny,
down in North Carolina from Minneapolis.
And so I just, you know,
I learned to love America.
It's gorgeous.
I mean look at this wooden barn.
Look at these cattle.
You know, things are going to change.
Wooden barns could be gone someday.
What do I decide, and you know, what's so great
is I haven't really been given much dictate.
So it's kind of like, just go for it.
So, but my problem is I have
trouble curbing myself.
If I go into a state, I really
want to get everything.
If I'm in Pennsylvania, I want
to show the Amish community.
I want to show the farmers.
But I also want to do the big city
neighborhoods, the vegetable man.
And I can't stop.
I don't know how to stop.
I want to show the different seasons.
I want to, if we race, we
race as fast as we can.
We work 13 hour days.
And then when it rains, we'll stay
inside to make sure we have metadata.
My husband goes with me on the
road, so that really is helpful.
And he writes the metadata,
and I take the images.
But it's, everything is so fascinating.
I mean, look at New Orleans.
I can't stop.
I need to go out every day.
And if you go into the French
Quarter in New Orleans,
you're always going to be
entertained and surprised.
And it's so much fun because
I'm now working with equipment
that can handle just about anything.
It can handle low light.
It can handle, I can leave my camera open
for an hour and catch the stars at night.
Look at Route 66 in America,
or just a big football game.
Or, you know, it's a never ending thrill.
This is taken, this image was taken
when I studied the state of Alabama.
That was the first day that I really went
into and studied very, very, very seriously.
This man knew Martin Luther King.
There he is a barber.
He knew Martin Luther King very well.
Wow. I couldn't stop talking to him.
Of course, I've been to the
cherry blossoms a million times.
I can never get enough.
I always have to run down there if I'm
in town during the cherry blossom season.
This is infrared camera, believe it or not,
a black and white infrared camera that I use.
It kind of makes everything dreamy.
But I like to shoot in black
in white sometimes just
because it's something different,
and it's kind of artistic.
I try to not do too much art
because my task is to show America.
And to show it clean and clear so that 100
years from now, or a 1,000 years from now,
when digital is maybe gone, or certainly a lot
of the cell phone images we're taking are gone.
We can see America.
What America looked like.
This is, believe it or not, a replication of
an image that Francis Benjamin Johnston took.
I took this.
She was there also.
So I had to go right back to the scene.
>> Thank you, Carol.
I think we'll all be grabbing our
cameras and wanting to be on the road.
The next section of, I've picked on
everyone's, the education outreach folks.
They helped us choose one state to hone in on.
We've had a taste of Alabama,
the man who knew Martin Luther.
Of course football for the Crimson Red.
But let's start in a little deeper, Carol, and
talk a bit more about not just how you come
up with an individual photo but how you're
thinking through this whole scheme of 50 states.
>> Well my scheme is, first of all, I want to
absolutely during my lifetime do all 50 states.
No question on it.
But, you know, when I'm in a state,
all I can think about is that state.
What is important here?
It's the nuances, along with the
historic images, along with the big scene.
So this is Alabama.
As I'm traveling, let's say
I want to do Birmingham,
and then I go to a smaller
scene, something like this.
I will oftentimes catch things on the way.
So I keep my eyes peeled
for everything, anything.
Animals are important.
Foliage is important.
All of our historic properties are
highly important, so I look for those.
This is an old Civil War scene.
It was the last Civil War
battle, the last one period.
They didn't get the word,
and they were still fighting.
The Civil War was over.
So it's a gravesite.
This is the Selma.
I went to the march.
So I look for important events
that have happened in the states.
I'm interested in teeny tiny towns.
I'm interested in big city neighborhoods.
I'm interested in landscapes.
Obviously in Alabama the Civil War was very big.
This was a reenactment.
So I just open my mind to
what is that state all about?
And the beautiful race cars at Tuscaloosa.
How important, I'm sorry, not Tuscaloosa,
but how important the various events are.
That's incredible.
>> From my notes, Carol, it says
Talladega, so that may be the word.
>> Yeah, I mean Talladega.
Yeah that's the [inaudible] word.
>> It's at Talladega, super-speedway.
Supposing.
>> Yeah.
>> Supposing that the teachers wanted
to have their students do a little
community preservation through photography,
I'll keep rolling through
some more scenes from Alabama.
But what advice might you give them
if they wanted to become creators
of primary source research documents?
>> Okay, so maybe you want to follow my mindset.
And that is, how are things going to change?
Will football still be around,
let's say, during your lifetime?
If you have a 13-year old
student, and you say to him,
well let's go out and shoot a football game.
You know, it's been around for a very long time.
Now it's changed some.
But will it be around when you're 90 years old?
And what is it that's fascinating
about football?
Or theater?
What's fascinating about it?
How has it changed?
How will it change?
So everything will become
historic during your lifetime.
Just a little class of what do they look like?
You know, I remember these look
like they might be girl scouts,
and I remember when I was a girl scout.
So I think I would say to students, why
don't you just put on your thinking cap
and see what you can capture
that you think might change.
And then we'll talk about it, you know.
I photograph everything because
I think everything will change.
Because it did.
IT changed from Francis Benjamin
Johnston's time.
But I think students need to think about that.
That they're in the here and now,
and maybe they're not thinking about.
They're probably thinking the cellphone
images they take, for instance,
the selfies, will always be there.
Will they?
So maybe they need to think
about, and then to maybe think
about their small towns or wherever they live.
What might disappear even in ten years?
Or fifteen years?
This Hillcrest Motel, probably is gone by now.
And then sometimes just photographing
things that might be important
to them and why they're important.
Why is a city scape important?
Why is it important, have the water, have
the city scape reflect into the water?
Water, will that be forever available?
I mean look at California and some of
the difficulties it's had, and Texas.
Well, it's always fun to
do any kind of carnival.
I love carnivals.
And I think kids would too.
And to, you know, to do creative
things, do photography at night.
And now, of course, cellphones
can capture almost anything.
So I think kids would, I would just
advise them to see things, see,
look around their communities and take
images of everything, just for interest sake.
Things they're interested in
or maybe not interested in.
>> Thanks, Carol, those are real good tips.
We're going to take a shift
now a little bit and think
about one aspect of what you already covered.
The phrase is often vanishing America.
So photography as primary source documents can
be really important for seeing change over time.
You spoke about that.
But then there's also the challenge of some
things are going to completely disappear.
And how do you go about, the word capture is in
my mind, but your photographs are special to me,
Carol, because you managed to get an
entire story within a single frame.
What you said about documentary value, as much
as artistic composition, clarity of color.
And so, again, back to that,
there are millions of choices
about what you could be photographing.
The thing in this section here will be the
vanishing America and what it means to you
that it will be your photograph that
is all that is left of say a barn,
like a Mail Pouch, with a Mail Pouch tobacco ad.
>> You know, when I take a photograph,
I am clueless as to what I'm taking,
whether or not what I'm taking
will be here a year from now.
Unfortunately, I've seen things
disappear that didn't, I didn't want to,
and that was I took photographs
of the World Trade Center
from the air, and a month later, it was gone.
But I use the word disappearing America.
I've done a great deal of time on Route 66.
I photographed a lot of old motels and
two-lane highways and old gas stations.
I did a pure station the other day.
This is, believe it or not,
a scene from Katrina.
It wiped out the Waffle House
and left four seats.
But it is really not for me to know.
I am interested in everything, but as
I'm traveling through the United States,
there's a lot of kind of, you know, small towns.
Some of them are not doing that well.
Some are doing very well.
But, you know, barns, old railroad cars.
Old cars. They're just fascinating.
And you know, I can't travel across America.
Oh and by the way, I don't fly.
We only drive.
That's all we ever do.
This is Big Tex.
Guess what.
This image, I took, and two weeks later,
it had been standing for 60 years.
Two weeks later it burnt to a crisp.
Burnt down.
So there we go.
There we go again.
I took an image, and it's gone.
So how wonderful that at least it
exists, and the Library of Congress,
there's nothing like the Library of Congress.
They, the Library of Congress
is all about preservation.
That's what it stands for.
And that's what I stand for.
And there's no better place to have my
images than the Library of Congress.
But, you know, look at this old place.
Look at phones.
You know, I see them every once in
a while, I still see pay phones.
And I take photos of them.
Because they're just about gone.
So technology is changing our life.
Old lighthouses.
We have about 900 left in the United States.
So, I am, I consider myself a preservationist.
I am taking historic properties.
I'm taking photographs of cities, states,
regions, tiny towns, whatever, I don't care.
Everything's America.
But I have great satisfaction in the fact that
they're going to be preserved in a place that,
there's no better place than the Library
of Congress to have them preserved.
Because that's what the Library of
Congress stands for, preservation.
>> Thank you so much, Carol.
Having had a good look at buildings,
whether it's Big Tex standing for 60 years
and all of a sudden, catastrophic fire.
He's disappeared.
Or the gradual of operation of pay phones from
our, [inaudible] our new technology comes about.
The pictures are rich.
Lots of detail to look at and think
about and reflect on with students.
But as interesting as the built environment is,
we're going to turn now to the wonderful people,
the heart of communities, and the
photographs you've made in that way.
Tell us something about each
of these pictures please.
>> Well, this was in New Orleans.
I just happened by these women,
and they were having so much fun.
So I had fun with them.
And I just photographed them and their babies.
We just had a ball.
I said guess what.
I said when your babies are 90 years
old, they can look at this photograph
and see what they looked like when they were
babies on the Library of Congress website.
Oh and little of, you know, county
fairs and animals and young people.
And everybody, families, and
people just having a good time.
Oh man, America is just filled with it.
And look at this little lemonade
stand, you know.
Francis, I wish you would
have been with me that day.
I think she would have loved it.
And this was a place where they make
quilts, believe it or not, in Alabama.
And her children were helping
her make this quilt.
And oh, it just meant a great
deal for me to be with them.
And just somebody just doing a
little skateboarding, and, you know,
murals are all over America,
in every town just about.
And so it's just fun to kind of capture people.
And look at these reenactors.
This was right outside, right next
to the White House, is Lincoln,
Jefferson and Washington reenactors.
The kids must have loved it.
And this is a little scene in New Orleans.
I've spent a lot of time
in New Orleans, by the way,
because Francis Benjamin Johnston
lived there, and I love it so much.
This is a little jazz band in one
of the places on Bourbon Street.
And this is an ice cream vendor.
Snow cones they call them.
And just kids.
And this is a little scene I
caught in Texas, believe it not.
This man was a veteran, and he was homeless.
And he was with his daughter and his dog.
And I treated them to a little meal afterwards
because they were so wonderful for me.
And they let me, they posed for
me for about a half an hour.
And it just meant the world to me.
And this is a football game, yay.
I think this might have been Alabama or Auburn.
I don't know.
I just loved it.
And this is chess players in
New York City believe it or not.
I mean look at America.
Look how rich it is.
Look how fun.
>> So Carol.
>> Yes mam.
>> I was going to say let's go
ahead and take 30 seconds and look
at that picture, but it's disappeared on us.
So we'll pick the next one.
>> Okay.
>> Back to that idea that
photos are rich in information,
multi-purpose can be used
all kinds of different ways.
Our final section.
Yeah our section focuses
on the natural landscape.
The people pictures were great and glorious.
You often say, Carol, it's our choice
to focus on a brighter side of America.
You're showing the homeless veteran,
young children who knows how
their lives will turn out.
The destruction of Katrina and September 11th.
And yet, photographs almost
always have a purpose and a point.
And yours is to make sure that people see
an optimistic or positive side of America.
So as we look at these photographs that
sometimes have me ready to sing the song,
Oh Beautiful for Spacious Skies, if you could
talk just a little bit about how you came
to your philosophy of photography and
how that is such an important part
of understanding the primary sources.
>> Well, you know, America is vast.
And you really get that when
you stand in a national park.
We're about to celebrate our national
parks next year, our centennial year.
And, you know, it's just gorgeous.
Now this is a windmill way
out in the middle of nowhere.
But just, you know, you look across
our land, and it's just magnificent.
It's huge.
And I think everybody even from overseas
gets that, that America is an enormous place.
You know, I just came from Wyoming where
you just, the landscape is just forever.
You can look across it, and there seems to
be just no ending to what you're seeing.
This is just a sand dune.
We have many sand dunes.
We have sand dunes in Wyoming.
We have them in Colorado.
We have them in many states.
This is the California coast.
Now that's another place where
you can look out over the ocean.
And it seems like you can just see forever.
It's all-inspiring is what it is.
And how lucky we are.
These are our redwoods.
I didn't know what to do when I got to the
redwoods because you can't capture them
in one photograph, no matter
how tall your camera is.
Because they're huge.
This is just a little scene in Hawaii.
Just a little, you know, near a lake almost.
Everywhere you go, it's scenic.
Even in small towns, believe it or not.
We have all of our, certainly on the east
coast, and in the Midwest, we have our seasons.
So that is a whole other scenic view.
This is very near my house in Washington
D.C. And then you go to the time of tulips.
Well tulips last maybe a
week or two, and that's it.
So you run around to get
them everywhere you can.
Our botanical gardens are just magnificent.
And then we have all the structures.
This is in Arizona, Utah.
They're called slot canyons because
little slots of sun come through.
They're gorgeous.
They're absolutely magnificent.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes, I'm sorry.
>> No that's alright, Carol.
I thought you had the perfect tagline for
bringing our slideshow to a conclusion.
Magnificent America.
We're going to take the rest of the time
to hear some questions from the teachers,
and we'll try to convey them
to you as clearly as we can.
>> Hi, this is Cheryl from
the Library of Congress.
I've been collecting questions
as they've shown up in the chat.
And if you haven't put a question
in the chat, go ahead and do that,
and we'll get to as many as we can.
One of the questions that you had that I
saw was about digital and around the phase
that Carols said when digital was gone.
And one of the participants was wondering if she
expects that our digital images will disappear.
>> Well, you know, that's
an interesting question.
I don't know, and it's not for me to know.
But isn't it fascinating to
you that film is almost gone?
So does that say to you that maybe
it might be 500 years from now,
that maybe digital will maybe
not be gone but may change.
That listen, during my lifetime, there have
been many things that have come and gone.
Cassettes, video used to
be on huge two inch tapes.
Super eight movies that my dad used to take.
So things are changing, have changed,
have changed greatly in my lifetime.
So I don't know.
And I'm not one to know, and I
don't think anybody really knows.
But they may.
Things may change.
>> Thanks Carol.
Somewhat related question was a follow up.
You mentioned that your husband collects
metadata, and somebody was interested,
a couple of people were interested
in what kind of metadata he collects.
>> Well what I meant by that is there's
no way that I can give Helena an image
that doesn't have metadata on it.
If I take an image, and I just submit it to
the Library of Congress without anything on it,
how will you who, hopefully, are going to use
this collection, have any clue what it is.
So every image I take has
GPS on it and has metadata
so that we can convey to you what this is.
What is this scene?
>> Terrific.
Let me process.
>> Cheryl, I'll jump in just to add, in
terms of preserving the digital photographs,
the Library of Congress is very fortunate to
have skillful staff who are deeply committed
to migrating these digital images from
one type of storage media to another.
So we'll be working hard to preserve them longer
than the contents of the scene will ever survive
in the same way we've done a great
job with preserving film photography.
And on that metadata front, Carol's right.
I'm pretty fierce about it.
But we like to have a title, the date the photo
was taken, the place where she was standing.
If things go well, we'll also have
latitude-longitude, so geospatial,
very precise recording in the future.
Carol is a master of keeping up
with the latest of new technology.
And so, while we have a basic idea
of content, subject, when and where,
we're also open to adapting if
she can bring in more metadata
and information into each photograph.
Thank you.
>> Yes. And let me just say one more thing
to that, and that is that, that is correct.
That is the reason that I had to
go to the Library of Congress.
There's no better place because of the fact
that that's what the Library
of Congress is all about.
Being able to preserve our heritage.
>> Fantastic.
The next question coming
in is about your process.
Again, how do you decide what angle
to capture and what story to tell?
I guess that's two questions.
So tackle that how you like, Carol.
>> Well I'm always looking for the
sun on my back so that if I'm out,
I want that sun behind me if possible.
Because I want the scene very well lit.
The other thing is, you know, after you've done.
I mean I'm 35 years on this.
So after a while you really kind of become
almost second nature at capturing things.
Because this is what I do, and
I do it every day, all day.
I mean every weekend, always.
I love it.
I can't say that enough.
And so therefore, after a while, you just kind
of, it becomes very, very, very second nature.
But well-lit is important, so that
everyone can see the scene and understand it
and see how beautiful it is or not.
>> Carol, what state will you tackle next?
I think I saw a question go by wondering if you
were coming towards New Hampshire any time soon.
>> You know, I've been to New Hampshire.
I actually had a book on the Mount
Washington Hotel, believe it or not.
And yes, I did capture old man
in the mountain, before it fell.
That's the other thing is that, you know,
even our natural landscapes
sometimes can have disasters.
But I don't think I'm up in
New England any time real soon.
But I certainly have it on my
radar screen, that's for sure.
>> Then tell us a little about the
states you're traveling in today.
Because I know we got a great
bunch of photos from you recently.
>> I just spent about four
and a half months on the road.
I was in Wyoming.
Beautiful Wyoming.
Wild Wyoming.
Gorgeous Wyoming with Yellowstone and
the Teton, and all that it offers.
And then Colorado and its, the mountains
and the, again, it's breathtaking.
That's why I have to kind of catch my breath
talking about either one of those states.
And then I just spent about
two weeks in West Virginia,
trying my very best to get
into a working coal mine.
It looks like I'm going to get in, but it
might be a few weeks before I can do that.
But so, and of course, you know, traveling back
and forth through these states, to these states.
So I go through the Midwest.
I'm going to be working some
in the Midwest next year.
So I have a very full year next year.
I think I'll be in most of the American
states next year, believe it or not.
Well I just, I'm going to go back to Wyoming
and Colorado during the winter
months and the spring months.
>> Carol, to wrap up, it looks, I think
Cheryl may have just two more questions.
Do you ever miss working with film?
>> No, you know, I'm so, well first of all,
I'm working with camera equipment that's
so iconic I can hardly deal with it when I
look at it on my computer, it's magnificent.
So no, I really don't.
So what I'm capturing is
what we call born digital.
And that is that if I worked in
film I would have to come back,
scan it, get the dust off, which is huge.
And then do the metadata and the
color correcting and everything else.
Now I come back and it's ready to go.
Now, I still have to do some color correction
and some adjustments, but
it is so much easier for me.
And also, it is a four by five piece of film.
The cameras that are working, that I'm
working in now are five times the size
of a scanned four by five piece of film.
So, you know, how can I, it's
just fantastic where I am headed.
Now, it's a lot of money, but it is worth
for the Library of Congress collection.
It is worth having fine equipment
so that you all can use it.
And by the way, what's so
wonderful about the Library
of Congress is they put these
images on in various sizes.
So if you just want a small
size, you can have one.
It's fantastic.
>> Carol, we're out of time.
It's 4:50, and I think you may have found
the perfect ending, the word fantastic.
I've really enjoyed talking with you today.
Even though we've had many conversations
before, I always learn new things from you.
I will keep that phrase, the
sun at my back, closely in mind.
And it's been great for all of you who
participated, watching your questions
and comments and observations come through.
Thank you for being so engaged with us.
>> Thank you, Helena, and thank
you, Carol, for joining us.
This was a fascinating discussion,
and I can't thank you enough for all
of your time, energy and efforts.
And sharing your resources with us.
A couple of housekeeping items for our audience.
You can take, we'd love to hear your feedback.
There is a link to a survey monkey.
Please make sure that you click
through that and give us some feedback.
It's three questions.
Shouldn't take you more than a minute or two.
You will receive information
within the next five business days
about receiving your certificates
for one instructional hour
after completion of this session.
And that goes for the folks who
are listening to the recording too.
We are recording all the sessions for our
online conference, and they will be available
through the teacher's page at
loc.gov/teachers, starting next week.
And we will send you an update as
to when everything gets updated.
And continue the conversation.
Lots of great ideas were
shared in the chat today.
So please, feel free to keep the
conversation going via Twitter.
Our handle is at TeachingLC,
and the hashtag is LCTeachConf.
So again, I can't say thank you
enough to Carol Highsmith and Helena
for the great conversation today.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit at loc.gov.